hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
will jetzt nicht erschrecken ich steh
nicht in meiner neuen kirche sondern in
einem küchenstudio ich bin im
küchenstudio schmidt im keller will man
hier genau aussieht das soll jetzt keine
werbung sein sondern meine eigene küche
ich einfach noch nicht fertig und ohne
küche kann ich ja keine videos für euch
machen und ich stehe hier in der küche
und möchte einfach ein ganz einfaches
rezept für euch machen und zwar habe ich
mir überlegt dass ich heute
quarkbällchen macher weil einfach schon
viele danach gefragt hatten
und ich habe bereits letztes jahr oder
vorletztes jahr ein bild davon bei
facebook hochgeladen habe und deswegen
zeigt sich jetzt einfach mal die zutaten
die zubereitung geht auch ganz schnell
ihr braucht gar nicht viel dazu also ich
hatte nicht mal eine vage da und da
zeige ich euch jetzt einfach mal die
zutaten und zeigt euch damit es
weitergeht an zutaten braucht ihr 500
gramm quark ich habe hier den magerquark
400 gramm mehl vier eier 250 gramm
zucker eine packung backpulver eine
packung vanillezucker oder einen
esslöffel selbstgemachten vanillezucker
und einen teelöffel salz und zum
frittieren braucht ihr natürlich etwas
öl ich habe ziehen maiskeimöl könnte
auch eine neutrale sonnenblumenöl nehmen
oder eben ein frittieröl und zur
fertigstellung brauchen wir etwas zimt
ich habe jetzt hier zwei teelöffel und
habe ein glas voll mit zucker das sind
etwa 150 gramm
aus diesen zutaten stellen jetzt ganz
schnell einen rührteig her und wie ihr
seht benutze ich heute nur ein
schneebesen unterrühren schlüssel
das geht nämlich alles ganz ohne
elektronik und das zeige ich euch jetzt
schnell und jetzt geben wir einfach alle
zutaten nacheinander in diese schüssel
also mehl salz vanille zucker backpulver
und zucker
jetzt kommen die eier mit dazu
und auch der quark das wird jetzt
einfach mit dem schneebesen kurz
verrührt das geht am anfang ein bisschen
schwieriger aber dann wird es immer
besser er wird einfach doch einen teig
schaber genommen weil es mit dem besser
geht
okay dann ist der teig fertig der muss
nur ganz kurz verrührt werden das geht
ganz schnell
jetzt gebe ich mein öl in einem topf und
erhitztes öl und zwar habe ich das jetzt
auf stufe neun ich weiß aber dann runter
schalten auf stufe sechs ich möchte mich
nicht dass das fett zu heiß wird
das soll so etwa 170 grad haben und
jetzt gebe ich einfach so etwa 2 bis 3
cm öl in den topf ich sehe jetzt noch
während ich das fett ein fülle wird es
schon richtig warm das sieht man hier an
diesen kleinen mustern und man riecht
auch und ich finde es wirklich
wahnsinnig ich hatte ja bisher keinen
induktions halt und das ist jetzt ein
induktionsherd und es geht wirklich
wahnsinnig schnell
ja das wird nicht heiß ausmachen also
das wird schon heiß weil durch das fed
wird an der topf heiß aber die platte
hier schon fast die glocke schlichtheit
und schwarz
das ding ist nur dass der topverdiener
war und durch die wärme vom topf werden
die platte ein bisschen warm ob es
wirklich heiß also platte an sich ist
nicht heiß aber durch die rücknahme von
dem topf wird müssen uns beeilen ich
schaltete jetzt auch gleich wieder
runter weil mir das zu schnell geht und
holt einen gefrierbeutel und mein
schwäbischer man muss jetzt kurz
assistieren und zwar habe ich einen
gefrierbeutel können dann natürlich auch
mit dem einwegspritze beutel machen aber
mit einem gefrierbeutel klappte super
und dafür jetzt den teil 1 und jetzt
richtig gut fest bitte ich mache jetzt
mal nur die hälfte
jetzt will ich das alles hier unten in
eine ecke ich drehe das oben mal zu euch
eine schere
ich hab jetzt keine schere deswegen
nehme ich jetzt einfach ein messer und
improvisiertes hier einfach ein bisschen
und schneider vorne eine ecke ab und da
hatte bekannte so etwa 3 cm
also soll nicht zu klein sein weil wir
richtige quarkbällchen möchten
und jetzt nehme ich das und geht es ins
heiße fett bezahlt ich dann nur holzstab
rein und wenn sich das schnell bläschen
bilden dann ist es fett heiß genug
ihr seht es dauert da jetzt ein bisschen
und ich bin jetzt am überlegen ob ich
nicht doch auf stufe sieben schalte ich
mach das jetzt mal
und butt noch einen kleinen moment und
kann in der zeit schon mal meinen zucker
vorbereiten und zwar gebe ich jetzt
einfach in so einem flachen gefäß meinen
zucker mit rein und meinen zimt und
verrührt es ganz kurz und habe so meinen
eigenen zimt zucker hergestellt und da
könnt ihr so viel zeit nehmen wie ihr
möchtet wir mögen es gern mit vielen
teams
deswegen habe ich auch zwei teelöffel
jetzt wahrgenommen oder korrektur zu
nehmen oder rohrzucker
ja aber ich finde es mir gut gehen wir
zurück zum öl das nimmt heißt es
probiert es hier nochmal und ihr seht da
steigen jetzt die bläschen hoch und ich
versuche jetzt einfach mit dem ersten
stückchen und zwar nehme ich jetzt meine
tüte und drücke da den teig raus etwa
die größe und nehmen das messer und
schneit es einfach runter jetzt warte
ich erst mal das erste ab und ich sehe
zum beispiel hier ich brauche noch ein
bisschen mehr fett als ich dass es eine
auspacken und gibt dann noch etwas meist
rein und wollen sich austria fährt
braucht und es sehe hier zwei eben nicht
genug platz zwischen topfboden und
oberfläche ist deswegen gebe ich dann
noch ein bisschen mehr in das schön
stimmen kann
glock nein noch nicht muss erst warten
bis das haus ist sonst kühlt das fest ab
und dann paar stunden halten muss
genau ist es fertig ist das ist
natürlich das feld erinnern kann
als ich nehme das erste schon mal raus
weil es jetzt eine schöne goldbraune
farbe hat gebe es noch etwas mehr fett
hinzu mein erstes belgiens ihnen darin
übrigens so aus also das fett war ein
bisschen zu heiß und ihr seht ihr dass
es etwas wo ist das heißt ich schalte
mein fett doch unter auf stufe 6 sodass
die bällchen etwa 23 minuten garen
können habe ich es trotzdem
ich tauche immer wieder mein messer in
das heiße fett um das hier schön
abzuschneiden und ich zeige euch auch
gleich noch eine zweite variante wie man
die bällchen formen kann
so meinen fetish grad zu heiß ich komme
mit dem induktionsfeld man nicht so gut
klar und geht man einfach nur ein
bisschen kalt ist aber nicht sagte ein
punkt zu lassen
ganz vorsichtig denn heißes fett tut weh
die müssen frei schwimmen weil die
tränen sich nämlich von alleine mit mir
auch jetzt klebt aber eine die müssen
einfach ganz frei schwimmen könnten
könne
denn die drehen sich dann auch von
alleine du siehst ist jetzt auch hier
und hier
was für andere trick das zeige ich
gleich wenn die raus sind
und die brauchen jetzt so etwa 1 bis 2
minuten
also eher etwas länger als kürzer damit
sie eben innen schön durch sind und ihr
seht die drehen sich ja auch von ganz
alleine
auf der einen seite gerne filme schädel
ist sozialismus
meine eltern sind jetzt etwas seit drei
minuten hier drin und ihr habt auch
gesehen die drehen sich von ganz alleine
und ich sind auch richtig schön rund
jetzt nehme ich sie heraus und gibt sie
direkt in den zucker mit rein und
schwenkt das jetzt einmal damit die
schönen bedeckt sind und dann nehme ich
sie einfach direkt raus und gibt es hier
auf einen anderen teller
jetzt könnt ihr mal den unterschied
sehen zwischen denen die sind jetzt
super schön goldbraun gebraten und die
zwei hier auf dem teller sind leider
etwas zu dunkel weil mir da das weg zu
heiß wurde und die sind noch innen drin
richtig froh wenn ihr keinen
gefrierbeutel habt oder einen
spritzbeutel nehmen da einfach zwei
teelöffel tauchte kurz in das heiße fett
und kommt dann damit zu einem kleinen
ball und zwar müsste er den gar nicht
richtig formen sondern einfach herunter
gerutscht
einfach so ein bisschen hier rund formen
und dann kommt direkt ins heiße fett
nicht so schön das macht aber gar nichts
und dann geht's einfach weiter einfach
abstechen und in den teig insel necker
wenn man noch etwas zitronenschale mit
in den teig gibt aber wir haben hier
leider keine zitronen reife und deswegen
bringen wir auch jetzt eine zitrone nix
aber das finde ich wirklich sehr lecker
weil ich finde dass das super zu diesem
frittierten gebäck passt und zudem zimt
und zucker und eigentlich mag ich meine
quarkbällchen zitrone
so stehen jetzt übrigens die fertigen
bällchen aus als hier ein komplett mit
zucker bedeckt und hier einst nur mit
etwas zucker bedeckt ich zeige euch mal
wie das innere aussieht
ab
falsch
o
ihr dürft ihr nicht zu früh probieren
und übrigens ist das ja auch die küche
im keller hinter jetzt auch bald meine
kochkurse geben werde
also ich habe bereits bei logischer
angekündigt dass sich backkurse geben
werde
und hier in dieser küche werde ich auch
kochkurse geben das heißt es gibt bald
ein kochen und backen mit city aber dazu
gibt's dann näheres in einem anderen
video und die termine werde ich
natürlich auf meine homepage auf
www.alice.de veröffentlichen
und da durfte ich dann alle anmelden und
dann kochen und backen wir hier
gemeinsam
wir mögen die quarkbällchen übrigens
nicht ganz gerne ganz so süß
deswegen nehme ich die bällchen und
taucht jetzt einfach nur mal kurz ein so
dass einfach die oberfläche so ein
bisschen zucker hat und gibt sie dann
auf meinen teller
falls sie den zucker gar nicht möglich
könnt ihr denn auch weglassen und zum
beispiel etwas zimt direkt mit in den
teig geben dann habt ihr einfach die
einfachen welchen ohne zucker außen rum
da spart ihr einfach nochmal etwas
zucker oder wer auch da kann zimt mag
nimmt etwas puderzucker
also da könnte das einfach so machen wir
das gerne möglich wäre es einfach nur
schnell meine welchen fertig machen
ich habe jetzt schon etwas und viertel
ausgebacken die hälfte davon haben wir
schon gegessen und so sehen sie jetzt
bisher aus ich backe jetzt einfach noch
meine bällchen fertig aus das war so das
rezept von und nachlesen könnt ihr
natürlich das ganze rezept auf
www.starbett.de
zum wochenende werde ich versuchen eine
muttertags torte zu machen weil sich die
viele von euch bereits gewünscht hatten
und weil es falls ihr da ganz besondere
wünsche habt also ob es etwas fruchtiges
sein soll oder eher etwas schokolade des
lustiges dann lasst mich das einfach
unten in den kommentaren wissen dann
werde ich das mit berücksichtigen und
auf jeden fall wünsche ich euch noch
einen ganz schönen tag
teilt man video wenn es euch gefallen
hat und lassen ein kommentar und eine
bewertung da und wir sehen uns dann vom
nächsten mal
bis dann und ich kriege ja auch eine
neue küche die habe ich mir übrigens
hier bestellt weil es hier echt richtig
tolle küchen hat und da kann ich euch
dann auch mal zeigen was ich was ich
persönlich in der küche ganz wichtig
finde und was auch allgemein wichtig ist
und was immer wir denken sollte
falls ihr euch eine küche zu legen
wollte ich werde euch auch gerne zeigen
wie man eine küche eingerichtet also was
ist logisch ist was man wo hinstellt und
gerne zeige ich euch da auch mal wie man
zum beispiel in den vorratsschrank oder
eine vorratskammer organisiert und wenn
euch sowas interessiert dürfte das gerne
in den kommentaren schreiben
dann werde ich euch dann nämlich videos
dazu machen ich möchte ich jetzt zum
beispiel man herzeigen einfach mal so
vorab und zwar ist es ein induktionsherd
und wenn man den bedienen möchte
schaltet man hier ein also mit einem
touchscreen und meistens ist ja so dass
man beim kochen so fertige hände hart
oder nasse hände und dann funktionieren
die meisten tages nicht mehr da muss man
als die hände waschen abtrocknen und
dann kann man sie wieder bedienen
und hier ist einfach so gelöst dass man
hier so einen magneten hat das ist schon
magnet knopf den kammern wegnehmen und
ich schalte es nochmal ein bis die
sicherheitsfunktion und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise diese herdplatte hier an
schalten möchte nehme ich den magneten g
auf dieses feld
das sieht man hier und dann kann ich
einfach den magneten drehen da geht
jetzt nicht an weil nichts drauf steht
moment wenn ich da jetzt aber einen topf
drauf stelle und dann einschalten
so geht er jetzt und jetzt ist er auf
der höchsten stufe oder wieder aus das
kann ich auch hier machen dann muss ich
eben diese platte hier bedienen
das problem schieber nur mein mann zum
beispiel der wichtigen nehmen und in die
hosentasche stecken und dann hätte ich
keinen knopf mehr